Fans sharing video reactions to movies, TV, and trailers.
Premium rental suits and tuxedos, delivered.
Hello, I'm the Nostalgia Critic. I remember it so you don't have to.
Y'know...I pick on this guy a lot.
Don't get me wrong. A lot of Adam Sandler films are awful to sit through,
coming across as lazy, unfunny, and even annoying.
But I forget sometimes that this is a mad talented person.
His songs can be great, his unexpected delivery can get a huge laugh;
even dramatically he can not only be good, he can be really good!
Sometimes, we let the worst of someone's work overshadow the good
and Adam Sandler does have a healthy amount of good work he's left behind.
That's why I'm gonna give credit where credit's due
and count down his top 11 best films--
(sounds of uncertainty from viewers)
Oh, I see. You don't think I can make it to top 11, can ya?
Well, y'know what? I'm gonna show ya!
They don't have to be masterpieces,
they don't have to be groundbreakers,
they just have to be worth the ticket fee to see them on the big screen.
And y'know what? Not only do I believe there's eleven,
I believe there can be even MORE in the future!
Please don't suck, please don't suck, please don't suck, please don't suck.
So, without further ado, I'm paying tribute to a flawed but still talented performer;
This is the top 11 best Adam Sandler movies!
(more sounds of uncertainty from audience)
There ARE eleven!
Hey, like I said, they don't ALL have to be masterpieces!
This is a cute comedy with a lot of character actors
that were soon gonna be big stars,
including Sandler, Brendan Fraser, and Steve Buscemi.
The three of them play band members of a group called "The Lone Rangers";
the name alone is already a beautifully stupid contradiction.
Trying over and over to get their band heard, they end up taking over the local radio station holding it hostage
only to have their cassette of their music be destroyed before playing it.
So...shit. They're stuck there for no reason not knowing what to do.
But the attention gets a lot of headbanger fans
to surround the building saying fight the establishment,
all while they're trying to figure out how the hell to get out of there.
A simple idea with simple jokes, but they're still effective.
The actors all have a dim-witted charm to them,
the commentary is obvious but still clever,
and the laughs, while not knee-slappers, do still get plenty of chuckles.
It's honestly a totally fine movie satirizing fame and media attention,
but this time with the heavy metal world.
It's totally serviceable. Not a glowing endorsement,
but if somebody asked if I'd recommend it, I'd say sure.
Like I said not a glowing endorsement, but a decent flick.
This movie is just the right amount of silly.
From visual jokes to funny actors to a downright bizarre premise,
Sandler plays an Israeli army commando who takes down terrorists,
but is sick of his way of life.
He fakes his own death so he can follow his real dream, which is...
Hairdresser. Yep, he becomes a stylist in New York,
and is apparently really good at it!
He even has the skills to take care of critics
who are either too harsh on him or his customers.
"Here comes the double foot."
"Smell it, smell it, smell it, now take it."
"That's for you."
Of course, when the bad guys find out he's still alive,
they try to hunt him down, and obviously, hilarity ensues.
Oh, and I don't mean that sarcastically.
I think this film is legitimately hilarious!
It was written by Judd Apatow
and Robert Smigel, [Triumph] the Insult Comic Dog.
It's totally in bad taste from beginning to end
and doesn't give a shit about it at all.
Mostly because it knows it's a dumb silly comedy,
but has a ton of fun with it.
The humor ranges from weird to really weird.
There is something so zany and over-the-top about this movie
that even when a joke doesn't work,
it's so surreal you can't help but still kind of giggle at it.
"No one can catch Phantom, woo!" *yell*
...what the hell is going on??
This is one of those films that got panned by critics,
but in my opinion still brings the laughs.
It's idiotic and won't further anyone's understanding of the world,
but screw it. It's just friggin' funny!
And that's enough for me.
This is one of those Sandler movies that flew under the radar.
While certainly uneven, most people agree this film
has difficult emotions being tackled
and a resolution that's not always clear and easy to understand.
Sandler plays Charlie, a man who lost his family in 9/11
and shuts himself off from the world.
His college roommate, played by Don Cheadle, meets him by chance
and sees how far he's slipped from reality.
He tries befriending him to make things better,
discovering that things in his life aren't always that great either.
The more time they spend with one another,
the more they find they're both making things better and worse for the other.
The film got mixed reviews when it came out,
which is not surprising as the movie is kind of a mixed bag.
It does sometimes feel forced and a little off,
but the reviews were still mostly positive
and I think that's what you can call it: mostly positive.
Even people who didn't like it had to admit there were still
strong moments from both Cheadle and Sandler,
giving an interesting and troubled look at two lives
who are lost for two very different reasons.
I see the problems with it, but I still think
the good stuff is too good to overlook.
For the number of times it plays it safe,
there's just as many times it takes a risk.
If anything else, it's good acting from a good cast,
proving once again Sandler can hold his own
even against cinematic greats like Cheadle.
If you haven't already, take a look. It's worth it in the end.
This Netflix movie came out in 2017 and had quite the cast,
including Sandler, Ben Stiller, Emma Thompson, and Dustin Hoffman.
The film centers around the Meyerowitz's dysfunctional family
and how the extremely eccentric father, played by Hoffman,
affected the lives of his kids, played by Sandler and Stiller.
And that's...really about it.
More of a character study than a plot-driven movie,
but these characters are interesting in how flawed they are.
Stiller is a successful businessman who hates everything his father stands for
while Sandler is more loving towards his dad,
but is also very lost emotionally and financially.
The two of them butt heads a lot throughout the film,
and they're both phenomenal.
Stiller gives a gut-wrenching speech near the end
and Sandler is so natural and believable,
it doesn't even feel like a performance.
It just feels like you're watching the troubles of a real guy.
The film itself can get a little grating due to Hoffman as the father,
but to be fair, I think that's kind of the point.
And I'd be lying if I said I was totally satisfied to what it all amounts to,
but it's still reasonably well-done and feels very real,
particularly with the performances.
In my opinion, I think it might even be Sandler's best acting.
I never once felt like he was lying or acting; it felt 100% real.
It's a unique film with some unique talent giving us some unique characters.
While it does have a lot of groaner moments and awkward jokes,
the comedy, romance, and ideas that DO work in the film
far overpower the ones that don't.
It's just a clever idea that surprisingly leads to some likable chemistry.
Sandler plays a veterinarian who falls in love with a seemingly charming woman played by Drew Barrymore.
The next day, however, she completely forgets who he is. Why?
Well, she has short-term memory loss, so her recollections only go as far as 24 hours.
So, every time Sandler sees her,
he has to either tell her who he is
or even more awkwardly, come up with
different ways for them to meet each time.
Her family wants him out the picture though as they like not having to
tell her every day about her condition, saving her the emotional stress.
Sandler can't help but still feel something for this person though,
despite the fact that she keeps forgetting who he is.
The chemistry between Sandler and Barrymore is
adorable, believable, and yes, even funny.
She does a great job selling that she's never seen Sandler
before over and over and over.
This could get old very fast, but she brings both the comedy and the humanity to it.
On top of that, Sandler coming up with new ways to try and explain
or even trick her into going out with him
not only shows his comedic side,
but also how much he cares about wanting to be with her.
I especially like the ending which, not to give anything away,
but they don't just cure the illness.
They do have to acknowledge the problem for the rest of their lives.
Most comedies like this would have the problem solved by the end,
but they go that extra mile in trying to be both delicate
and creative in living with the disorder.
It's a crazy romance that surprisingly has just as much heart as farts.
*groan* did I really just make that joke?
So yeah, the 80s are everywhere now.
Everybody references it. It's practically become a cliché!
But Sandler was one of the earliest people to poke fun at it,
waiting only eight years to understand what made it
stand out compared to modern day.
He plays a wedding singer who's jilted at the altar
and starts turning into an angry, bitter drunk,
but a waitress, played by Drew Barrymore, seems to help turn things around.
The only downside is she's marrying a jerk and yeah,
you know where this is going.
It's every 80s romantic comedy that, while following some clichés too close to the letter like having the fiancé be an unfunny jerk,
still manages to work with it okay because,
well, it is a satire of the 80s!
Was that intentional? Probably not.
But it works the same way Demolition Man is perfectly
representing the 90s without even knowing it.
The comedy gets a lot of laughs, I think everybody who
watched this movie has lines they quote from it.
"Things that could have been brought to my attention YESTERDAY!!!"
"Do you have any experience?"
"I'm a big fan of money. I like it. I use it. I have a little."
"[He's] losing his mind..."
"...and I'm reaping all the benefits..."
And, once again, the romance is very sweet.
Barrymore and Sandler had great chemistry
and this is where it all started.
Yeah, it's manipulative and contrived, but it's the same way shitty Christmas rom-coms are now;
you kind of accept how stupid they are and have fun with 'em.
And seeing how this is a throwback to the 80s,
doesn't it kind of make sense?
It's a lot of fun with just enough heart to make it work.
This is a predictable yet enjoyable film that still lasts long after the 80s.
"Woopity-doo!!"
Look at that suit. That is a nice suit.
A coat that's never been buttoned, a tie that's been tied once
so he can just keep reusing it over and over and over.
Okay, maybe the Nostalgia Critic suit isn't anything special.
But when I do want a good suit for special events, I go to TheBlackTux.com.
I mean, everyone wants to look good for that special event,
but they don't want to fork out a ton of money for it either
Well TheBlackTux.com is your answer, with high quality rental suits
and tuxedos delivered to your doorstep.
It's such an easy way to rent suits and tuxes online!
Most suits go for something like twelve hundred bucks,
but at The Black Tux, they start at ninety-five dollars!
They let you create your own look and choose from a ton of great stylists.
Their expert customer care has your back every step of the way
and it's completely done online.
You can even do a free home try-on so you can see the fit
and feel the quality of your suit months before your big event.
And after ordering your suit, they'll have it to you
fourteen days before the event even starts.
And if anything is less than perfect, The Black Tux
will send you a free replacement right away.
When your event is over, you just drop your rental
back in the mail and shipping is free both ways.
And hey, you want to get twenty bucks off your purchase?
Just visit TheBlackTux.com/NostalgiaCritic.
That's right. Just go to the TheBlackTux.com/NostalgiaCritic,
and you'll get twenty dollars right off your purchase.
Look good. Look smooth. Just look a little better than I do.
Hey, I'm rocking that hat though.
Visit TheBlackTux.com.
Premium rental suits and tuxedos, delivered.
Yeah, it's stupid. Yeah, it's immature.
Yeah, it's every dumb sports movie cliché in the world.
...but it's funny!
Sandler plays a hockey player named Happy,
who unfortunately sucks at what he does.
But when he discovers he has a great arm for golf,
suddenly he realizes he can make enough money
to save his grandmother's house.
Because of course there's a grandmother's house.
But the nasty mean bully--
because of course there's a nasty mean bully
--wants to stop him from stealing the spotlight as well as
his hot girlfriend who's in love with him.
Because of course there's a hot girlfriend who's in love with him.
Again, this is not a particularly story-based comedy.
The focus is on Sandler's attitude and the attitude of the people around him.
As phoned-in as these characters are written,
they're played by very funny people.
The angry nurse at the old folks home is played by a hilarious Ben Stiller,
Apollo Creed himself, Carl Weathers, plays a great bitter coach,
and Christopher McDonald might play one of the
funniest bullies in sports film history.
"Well, moron, good for Happy Gilm- oh my GOD!"
This is such a throwaway role, but he adds a delivery and energy that
makes him a comedic foil who's just as much fun as the comedic leads.
"I eat pieces of shit like you for breakfast."
"You eat pieces of shit for breakfast?"
"...no!"
Add on top of that the funniest cameo of Bob Barker ever,
a beautifully long list of completely meaningless deaths,
and enough lines to quote for years to come.
"Why don't you just go home? That's your home!
Are you too good for your home?!"
Happy Gilmore is just a fun dumb flick.
As the typical Adam Sandler movie formula goes,
this one arguably did it the funniest.
"The price is wrong, bitch."
Though a big hit with critics, audiences seem to
either love or hate this film.
Personally, I think it's so strange, so mysterious,
and so well-acted that I can't help but love it.
Even though I'll be the first to admit, I have no idea what it means.
Sandler plays a man named Barry, a quiet, awkward, reserved,
yet totally impulsive outcast who's emotionally abused by his sisters
and is being scammed and robbed by a call girl service.
As things get stranger and stranger,
a kind woman named Elizabeth, played by Emily Watson,
enters his life and finally starts to give it purpose.
From there, just weirdness. All sorts of weirdness.
This was written and directed by Paul Thomas Anderson,
the same guy who did Magnolia, Boogie Nights, and There Will Be Blood,
so that gives you an idea of the strange arthouse nature
that lies ahead with this film.
What's the point of it? Why does it exist?
Why is everything in it so odd and unexplainable?
I don't know, but it draws you in to where you kind of are okay with not knowing.
Between Sandler's brilliant acting, the surreal atmosphere,
and just downright bizarre method of storytelling,
It truly is a one-of-a-kind film you're either gonna get into or you're not.
Personally, I loved every minute of it
and a lot of that does come from Sandler
who carries a lot of this film with his performance.
It's a totally-out-there experience,
but still has me fascinated every time I see it.
Yeah, you might as well lump these two together.
The Hotel Transylvania movies are beautifully animated, extremely funny,
incredibly charming, hugely creative, and carry a surprising amount of heart.
Every release gets trashed by critics and I still don't understand why.
They're great for kids, great for adults, wonderfully written,
and wonderfully voiced with Sandler almost unrecognizable as Dracula.
In a world terrified of monsters, Sandler as Dracula builds a hotel
for all the famous Halloween freaks to come and relax.
His daughter Mavis though is growing restless
and wants to see the world.
Dracula is too afraid of what will happen to her though
due to what happened to his wife who was killed by an angry mob.
But when a young traveler visits telling her the world isn't what she thinks it is,
a drift builds between the two of them and the monsters
witness the real scares with the horrors of parenting.
These films were directed by Genndy Tartakovsky,
the creator of Samurai Jack,
and they have his stamp all over them.
They're fast, they're energized, they're brilliantly designed,
they throw a ton of various jokes at you,
and they surprisingly can be very moving.
Both films are fantastic at portraying very relatable family problems while
also getting tons of laughs based off of these hilarious characters.
These movies are becoming new staples of Halloween;
you just look at them and you get excited for the holiday.
Which is strange seeing how the third one is coming out in summer, but
I guess we can buy it around Halloween...?
Hopefully it's as good as the other two because
these films are incredibly funny as well as heartwarming.
Despite what critics say, this is a series of movies
I predict are going to get more and more popular
with every passing Halloween season
"Hit it!"
And the number one best Adam Sandler movie is...
Hear me out.
Funny People got mixed reviews when it was released
and most audiences left not really enjoying it all that much,
but under this seemingly pointless story
lies an interesting subtext if you connect it to Sandler's life
which you could argue the movie was doing already.
Sandler plays a comedic movie star named George Simmons,
but let's be honest, he's playing Adam Sandler.
He used to be a stand-up turned into a movie star
and his films seemed like quickly-turned-out fluff
that somehow make a lot of money.
He gets a shock though when he discovers he has leukemia.
Thinking his days are numbered, he goes back to stand-up
where he meets a writer, played by Seth Rogen, who also does stand-up.
The two of them form a friendship despite the fact that
Sandler doesn't always treat him that great,
but he's dying, what can you do.
Well suddenly, halfway through the movie, his leukemia is cured.
Yeah, complete recovery and everything.
So...where does the film go now?
Well, that's the same question the characters ask.
Now that Sandler is better, he feels he can still be a dick
and ignore all the mental pain he was confronting.
But Rogen tells him it isn't and shouldn't be as easy as all that.
The two go back and forth between respecting each other and hating each other,
ultimately resulting in an ending that honestly doesn't resolve that much.
If anything, it indicates that much of these actions will be repeated in the future and the changes made, if any, are very minimal.
So...
This is kind of really friggin' interesting.
The comedy is decent and the acting from everyone
is once again great, but really think about it.
If this character is supposed to be Sandler,
why do half of these choices happen?
We've seen films like Top Five or Lost in Translation or 8 Mile
where we know they're semi-autobiographical around the person playing them.
So why would Sandler have himself be such a jerk?
A jerk who's dying, no less?
Sandler is said to be one of the sweetest celebrities in Hollywood,
yet he portrays himself as a lost asshole who rarely learns his lesson.
Why would the film be so similar to his life in other aspects, but not here?
The short answer is I don't know,
but it's interesting to think about, isn't it.
The same way the Rocky movies kind of reflected Stallone's career,
the underdog becoming a star, turning into a joke,
then balancing out in his old age,
the same way we might see kind of a reflection here.
Sandler's comedies even he acknowledges sometimes have little to no substance.
He even says sometimes they're done just so he can vacation somewhere.
Yet he still makes them that way while also trying more experimental roles.
Could it be this is how he sees himself?
As somebody who is successful in some ways, but lost in others?
Is it an exaggeration of what he thinks he could become, has been, or currently is?
Maybe it's a cautionary tale for not just others, but himself as well.
Like I said, this is speculation. I have nothing to back this up,
but why have the character's career be so eerily similar?
Like any intriguing piece of art, I don't always know what the artist's intent is,
but what it reflects is even more fascinating.
The film is such a strange blur of fact and fiction that
you can't always pinpoint what's supposed to be real and what isn't.
If Sandler didn't play him in this movie,
the film wouldn't be as relevant, but he does.
Why? Why pick a role so seemingly similar to him and yet,
in many other respects, so seemingly the opposite?
It's a question I don't know if I'll ever fully get the answer to,
but it's also a question I don't fully need the answer to or even want.
The mystery of it is far more engaging.
It's like a Rorschach test of how much of the actor
and his career you see in the role,
and it can be a surprisingly compelling take given your point of view.
I can't act like I know this was the intention,
but the ideas are planted and they're worth talking about.
In a weird way, this Sandler movie more than any other
asks the most questions. It makes you think the most.
And given the actor's background of movies,
the one that makes you think the most
is the one I'm gonna put as number one any day.
Funny People is a fascinating reflection,
we just don't always know of exactly what.
I'm the Nostalgia Critic. I remember so you don't have to.
I GOT TO ELEVEN, HA--
Hey, Doug Walker here, doing the charity shout-out.
And this week, we are doing CEDARS Foster Care.
It is the mission of CEDARS to help children
who have been abused, neglected, and homeless
achieve safety, stability, and enduring family relationships.
Founded in 1947, CEDARS continues their vision today to
create a place where children can experience a real childhood
and begin planning for the future.
That simple act of kindness over 70 years ago has resulted in
thousands of children building new family lives,
offering young people safe shelter and the skills
to adapt to a quickly changing world.
Today's reality is harsh and not every home today is safe for every child.
Poverty, drug use, mental illness, criminal activity,
and neglect place children at extreme risk
CEDARS continues to respond, giving hope to youth in need
and direction to families struggling to stay together.
If you look at their site and their YouTube page, you can witness
all the wonderful people they bring together
and all the positive ways they help.
Check them out and see if you can play a big part in a child's future.